je suis sûr que vous avez hâte
d'entendre leurs réactions à chaud comme
ça je joins à ottawa daniel lessard à
toronto tasha kheiriddin est mort à
montréal michel david bonsoir à vous
trois alors d'abord je voudrais qu'on
fasse un petit tour de table rapide pour
avoir vos premières impressions qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé du débat michel
eeckhout et un débat à cinq
oui tout le monde n'a pas la même
maîtrise du français c'est pas toujours
évident mais je vous dirais céline que
je les trouvais plus intéressant que
celui de la semaine dernière à calgary
ce serait la raison suivante la semaine
dernière on n'a parlé que d'économie de
sorte que tout le monde avait finalement
répété en ligne ses propres lignes et
dans un contexte comme celui-là comme
monsieur trudeau avait les propositions
les plus novatrices son plaisir avec son
déficit pendant plusieurs années ces
investissements massifs en
infrastructures et les maires sortie
là on avait une panoplie de sujets qui
finalement servait mieux le but d'un
débat comme celui là qui finalement de
savoir lequel ferait le meilleur premier
ministre et et là je pense que
l'expérience même s'il s'est retrouvé
dans l'embarras en coupe deux fois
l'expérience de monsieur molière est
vraiment fait contraste avec monsieur
trudeau qui bien franchement sur un
certain nombre de sujets n'avaient pas
grand chose à dire quand on se met à
parler de de l'aide médicale à mourir et
qui dit beaucoup taylor c'est loin déjà
le fédéral puis est revenue sur ces
taxes
quand monsieur bah lequel woods écouter
ci sauve prend quelqu'un pourrait créer
vos lignes des fois ça valait vraiment
havrais là monsieur trudeau eu l'air
beaucoup plus du trudeau des démocraties
da qui avait peu de choses à dire on va
s'en garder un peu alors vous tâche à
vos premières impressions
mais moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié ce débat
aussi parce que pour les raisons que
michel a dit
c'était mouvementé il y avait beaucoup
de différents sujets ce que je trouve
intéressant c'était comment tous les
différents acteurs essayé d'introduire
leurs sujets préférés à un moment donné
c'est rudoiement c'est les f 35 en
parler d'autre chose là aussi mentionné
l'économique en parler de l'aide à
mourir
monsieur duceppe a mentionné les
pétrolières et elle a le bureau de la
compét' la concurrence c'est toutes
sortes de petites choses qui sont
rentrés dans le décor mais ça fait
intéressant le débat qui est sorti le
meilleur parce que c'est simplement
vista voir ça écoute je pense monsieur
duceppe à cause de sa langue a très bien
performé mais je sais pas s'il a
convaincu nécessairement que on devait
voter pour lui c'est éprouvant le
meilleur des batteurs des 5
mais je suis d'accord orienté c'est ça
et je suis d'accord avec michel que
monsieur mulcair a bien fait sauf qu'il
a perdu son coup la coupe de reprise
c'était pas bon pour lui et monsieur
harper la seule question je trouvais est
un peu et c'est vraiment pris par
surprise c'était sur l'arabie saoudite
dire c'est un allié c'était un peu
bizarre sa réponse là dessus ah mais à
part de ça et il a joué c'est le premier
ministre y est les monsieur trudeau
répéter toujours qu'il voulait baisser
les taxes alors c'était son message
j'imagine que vous l'alluré daniel vous
avez préféré ce débat celui la semaine
passée ah oui oui beaucoup lu un peu
cacophonie mais bon c'est de loin le
meilleur des bois de cette campagne
écoutez vous savez que j'aime beaucoup
le rac et je vais vous servez vous
servir de vos acquis pour vous en parler
je pense que la meilleure attaque
je suis d'accord avec mes collègues
étaient celles de gilles duceppe la
meilleure défense était celle de stephen
harper je pense que dans l'ensemble
thomas mulcair avait été le meilleur
sauf que vous savez très souvent c'est
la défense qui a une partie de hockey et
je vous dis sort pour une raison bien
précis c'est que cette campagne en ce
moment se fait sur deux sujets qui
soulève les passions le niqab et les
réfugiés et dans les deux cas ça s'est
fait entre thomas mulcair et s'ils
veulent un peu je pense que dans les
deux cas si stephen harper qui a été le
plus rassurant pour les électeurs qui ne
veulent rien savoir à 80 % et + du niqab
et autour de 60% de nos d'accueillir
plus de réfugiés
ouais justement on va écouter un extrait
de ce premier échange sur
ses chansons le niqab c'est le moment
qui a été le plus discuté sur facebook
alors on va l'écouter en échange entre
monsieur harper et monsieur mulcair sur
une gamme
jamais je ne vais jamais dire la maj une
fille qu'une femme devrait se couvrir le
visage parce qu'elle est pour vous
attaquez vous à l'oppression si vous
croyez qu'il ya oppression nadan et le
courage de faire ça mais c'est pas en
privant ces femmes de la citoyenneté et
de leurs droits que vous allez réussir à
les aider si monsieur harper continue à
se cacher tout le monde va comprendre
que pour lui c'est une arme d'une
interaction merci le serment à visages
dévoilés
c'est juste le gros bon sens alors on le
disait pour monsieur mulcair ça a été
difficile ce sujet toute la semaine y a
perdu des points dans les sondages à
cause de saint michel
comment est-ce qu'il s'en sort alors
souhaité que ce soit aussi parce qu'il
est en porte à faux avec l'opinion
québécoise et ce soir je comprends que
c'est pas un canadien mais c'était
surtout au québec j'imagine que monsieur
mode qu'un voulait disons rétablir les
choses et il n'y a rien et avenue du
tout je pense que quand monsieur ne plus
envoyer qu'il était prêt à sacrifier les
droits des femmes pour récolter des
votes à toronto
ça c'est le genre de chose qui fait mal
et il monsieur duceppe lui ont mis en
pleine face le consensus à l'assemblée
nationale mais aussi dans l'ensemble du
québec
je pense que monsieur môquet a pas gagné
grand chose sur ce plan là ce soir
tasha il était quand même pas isolé
avait madame mais qu'ils étaient
d'accord avec lui monsieur trudeau aussi
qu'elle va à peu près la même position
oui mais c'est très dur qu'il disait
toujours que le niqab c'est pas la
question ne devrait pas en parler alors
c'est pas un allié énorme écoute cbc
mulcair mais c'est trudeau parler votre
plus fédéraliste je dirais ce soir
monsieur mulcair devrait s'adresser à
l'électorat québécois en primeur et je
pense que il a décrit sa position mais
je pense que ça va pas être populaire
écoute c'est sans son opinion que c'est
la façon qu'on ait des femmes c'est en
leur permettant
de de faire ce qu'elles veulent mais je
pense pas que cet argument tient
beaucoup avec les québécois alors sur
celui là je pense que la meilleure
réponse
daniel est ce que ça va rester cette
question du niqab est ce que ça peut
devenir une question qui va jouer
peut-être dans l'isoloir comme on dit
moi c'est mon impression c'est que il ya
deux c'est l'économie c'est la santé
c'est l'environnement qui devrait être
au sens de sa campagne électorale
mais si absolument pas ça c'est le niqab
ce sont les réfugiés c'est là dessus que
les gens se préparent à voter vous allez
me dire il reste quatre semaines de
campagne
toutes choses qui peuvent se passer sauf
que pour l'instant ça s'envole à tuer
c'est pour ça que c'est très dommageable
pour thomas mulcair
je lui reconnais ce soir le courage
d'avoir maintenu et défendu une position
extrêmement difficile il perd presqu'un
point par jour
ils voient la victoire lui filer des
doigts si steven un peu qu'à l'air de
vouloir gagner là dessus sauf que ici
beaucoup trop avancé ne peut plus
reculer
alors on va écouter un autre extrait
celui là assez cacophonique vous allez
voir sur la question référendaire et on
vient vous trois répondent et dont la
question est ce que vous n'avez pas
assez de fédéral doit respecter la loi
référendaire du québec oui ou non cette
lettre est mon ami tu m'aimes sa part
écrit contrairement aux normes
vraiment non pas moi qui ai nommé sur
ces questions ouais alors clairement une
question qui a enflammé les débats ce
soir mais chelle qui s'en est le mieux
sorti c'est pas me suis pas monsieur
mike est encore une fois un peu comme
dans le cas d'une cape d'ailleurs il est
là il est vraiment écartelée entre entre
le québec et le canada anglais et il n'y
a pas répondu à la question monsieur
duceppe à ce que le gouvernement fédéral
devrait respecter les lois québécoises
ça ça veut dire concrètement ne serait
plus dans 50 pour 1 c'est plus un
c'était l'histoire des dépenses de
l'argent l'orgie de dépenses que le
gouvernement d'ottawa avait avait fait
la dernière fois en 95 et monsieur
maquette est évidemment pas pour dire
non non non non on mettra pas d'argent
là dedans et il s'est fait dire par
monsieur trudeau que ils étaient dix ans
il était
s'inquiétant de voir que cet homme là
pourrait devenir premier ministre je
pense que monsieur marquer l'accord a eu
de la misère ce soir tasha ben monsieur
michael dick si c'est assez bon pour les
cosses le 50 % + 1 c'est bon pour le
québec
je pense que il a décidé il a défendu sa
position là dessus mais c'est sûr qu'au
canada anglais c'est pas populaire
monsieur trudeau parlait plus à un
électorat fédéraliste il y en a un
électorat fédéraliste sensible au québec
aussi dans certains comtés
particulièrement à montréal je sais il
parlait directement à ces gens là ils
parlaient aussi directement au canada
anglais dans sa réponse à cette question
essentiellement accusant monsieur
mulcair d'être trop nationaliste alors
c'était vraiment un discours à
complément à deux vitesses et monsieur
harper lui bon on sait sa position là
dessus c'était assez claire aussi
c'est terrible de devoir faire le même
discours à deux vitesses là en même
temps est ce qu'il est daniel way
écouter à étonnant c'est que cette
question si elle serait un jour va se
régler au québec ce sont les québécois
qui vont la règle et a que 1 democracy
international serait quant au centre ce
c'est la règle si la question est très
claire un gars suède a fait un sondage
il ya deux semaines en demandant aux
canadiens quels sont vos priorités vous
savez à quelqu'un venait l'unité
nationale la question nationale l'avenir
du québec au 17e rang
ça a été ré c'est un pour cent des
canadiens ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
de cette campagne c'est pas là dessus
les gens vont voter même pas les
québécois
bon il ya aussi été question de
transport de pétrole on va écouter un
échange entre eux monsieur rappeur et
monsieur trudeau
c'est clair que le problème ce n'est pas
les pipelines ou les trains le problème
c'est le produit
nous avons besoin de restaurer la
confiance dans un gouvernement qui sera
arbitres et non cheerleader pour pour
pour des projets de pipelines et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que monsieur harper a
tellement de misère à avoir cette
confiance publique nécessaire pour
développer nos ressources et créer des
emplois une simple c'est intéressant
d'entendre les
les perspectives de ces parties très
négative envers le secteur énergétique
et les pipelines
c'est tout à fait le contraire content
d'en faire le débat à calgary tâche
alors est ce que monsieur après à raison
à ce que les discours changent en tout
cas il il accuse ses adversaires d'être
contre le pétrole quand tu n'es pas là
car premièrement alors sa voix très anti
pipeline n'était pas là mais si la
raison qu'à calgary est le discours sur
l'énergie était beaucoup moins négatives
et ce n'est pas surprenant parce que
l'auditoire est littéralement été
c'était dans le bassin du pétrole et ça
met en relief le fait qu'il ya
essentiellement deux campagnes parfois
qui se font au québec et un an le reste
du canada mais avec les réseaux sociaux
et l'internet est aussi impossible de ne
pas remarquer ces choses là les gens
sont plus au courant que jamais alors
cette hypocrisie est sorti justement
daniel whatwg à tous les niveaux n'est
pas crise il y est clair pour tout le
monde à commencer par lui-même que s'ils
veulent un peu rêve de faire du canada
est depuis longtemps une super puissance
pétrolière
y'a pas loin loin de son enfant n'était
pas très très loin de ce avant la chute
des prix du pétrole sur cette question
là comme sur l'environnement monsieur
rappaz des problèmes de crédibilité
oui et comment ça va passer tout ça au
québec michel rabeux écouter ou québec
je pense que sur ce plan là la cause de
monsieur harper et est entendu
mais c'est vrai que c'était assez
intéressant amusante va entendre de ce
très doux souvenez vous ça m'est revenu
en mémoire ce qu'avait dit à calgary il
y avait dit que avec des amis comme
monsieur un peu l'alberta va pas besoin
d'ennemis
alors on peut pas dire ça donne pas plus
aujourd'hui l'accusé d'être un
conditionnel compte secret du pétrole à
la roue il y avait une contradiction
mais mais il ya aussi
la réalité c'est que au québec la
position de monsieur de monsieur harper
ne passe pas là dessus et et monsieur
marc elle l'a aussi est suspect disons
que de tenir deux langages selon qui
parle au québec et à l'extérieur du
québec
intervenant à la performance du chef
parce que le chef dont il a été le plus
question sur sur facebook c'est justin
trudeau alors c'est c'est ça vous
surprend daniel à l'égard des petits
bois ça ne surprend beaucoup parce que
j'ai autant je l'avais trouvé bon dans
les deux des bonnes raclées autant j'ai
trouvé mauvais ce soir à comme michel
disant début souvent cédé des phases des
formules toutes vides
ils répondaient pas aux questions sans
arrêt dans d'autres directions alors
qu'on lui posait des questions très
précises
il ya eu beaucoup de difficultés en
français beaucoup beaucoup on sentait
qu'ils pensaient d'abord en anglais
avant avant pour le traduire en français
telle décision c'est pas sa meilleure
performance mais vraiment pas eu besoin
d'être pas mal meilleur que sur la
semaine prochaine à tva s'il veut faire
des gains au québec
ouais pourtant ils avaient ils n'étaient
pas très présent depuis le début de la
campagne au québec
donc il avait besoin de ce débat tasha
oui il était moins présent à ce débat
certainement que le débat du globe and
mail la semaine passée certainement mais
moi je n'étais pas aussi négatifs à son
égard je pense qu'il a essayé de faire
passer oui ces messages mais son message
par exemple de baisses de taxes et pour
les autres chefs je pense que écoute
c'était pour moi vraiment le plus
intéressant de regarder monsieur duceppe
et monsieur mulcair et comme j'ai dit
monsieur mulcair a bien fait mais il ya
huit ans mais sorti une couple de fois
je pense que l'approché des prochains
débats ils devraient le renfermé parce
que c'est pas ça dans un premier
ministre que les gens veulent voir alors
michel en terminant est ce que ça peut
changer quelque chose ce débat
d'après-vous non je pense pas que ça
peut changer sinon mais c'est ça qui
dans le fond de changement des derniers
jours on a vu que les conservateurs ont
en plus qu'à raffermi leur vote on sent
vraiment monter et que monsieur monsieur
moquer de la misère je pense que ce
qu'on a vu ce soir ne fera rien pour
changer ça et ça c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle certainement pour monsieur
marquer enfin quelq'un d'air on disait
au début que près ça serait une icône
une campagne clac c'est tout sauf la de
cette campagne et puis ça se poursuit
pour encore quelques temps merci
beaucoup à vous trois
la semaine prochaine les dimanches à 11h
aux coulisses du pouvoir emmanuelle
latraverse s'entretient avec elizabeth
may du parti d'air